yo crazy you didn't make the freshman
cover by the way it was one of the
wildest snubs of the Year
man I don't feel like it's a snub though
I thought it was I don't why not I don't
either I mean last year there was two
guys from Detroit right this year I was
like yo like I mean Detroit to me just
moving even faster bigger I don't feel
like I'll do it you got one of the best
albums of the Year enough I ain't did
enough
I don't know man I don't know bro
yeah maybe next year like but as far as
as far as like you saying that that
ain't like
you shut up bro cause I'd be saying I
don't feel like I did enough though like
like as far as musically right like yeah
for my city I'm big in my city and stuff
like but like on the worldwide level
yeah I got a record now you're not logo
again it's [__] on that that made that
[__] that's that's not worldwide
neither and like bro but you not all
right so hit me up if you hear me you
know I know it's cool I just want to
talk to him bro [__] you not local you
did a whole [__] lot
uh a [__] alive they say they don't see
your [__] more so than bro it's the
[__] on that [__] bro I never heard
they names before and I'm not just
saying that because I want to tell you
to see your face you feel me bro you did
a lot brother but you know what I'm
saying and and and
more so than just saying you did a lot
bro I don't know what their standards is
or what they hold the bar from as far as
like what you doing but [__] you did
enough if I had to say something you
know what I'm saying to make the [__]
bro I understand you've done more than
I'd be feeling like it's different
Marcus and music maybe maybe they know
some stuff that we don't know you feel
me as long as I sell records and I
Elevate and I get better with my craft
I'm satisfied but I don't feel like like
I just wowed the whole world to where I
just had to be on the fresh release no
y'all saying that and y'all got y'all
got like your opinions matter to me
no bro okay so I I hear you saying that
but [__]
right there
all 12 of them didn't wow the [__]
world bro
like [__] is is granted it's some
[__] on there [__] yes I've heard
they music sure could I not but like
[__] I've heard your [__] non-biasedly
I've heard your [__] [__] more so
than I've ever heard a song from like
three people on them yeah there's like a
few people and there's no knock today
but [__] you feel me you know how I be
feeling about that situation as I hope
it's like [__]
I know you but now honestly I still
would know you and still not have heard
them [__] like say I wouldn't meet you
and I'm just on Tick Tock or Instagram
bro [__] yo songs is everywhere yeah
yeah gorgeous shit's going up gorgeous
right now but gorgeous wasn't really
going nothing but like no right now
right now let's go I mean that's what
I'm saying you still
yeah you was juicing but it's like I'm
I'm limited well back then I was limited
to a certain Market of people like and
gorgeous and they also probably put that
list together like
I heard that they a few people I bought
their way on this year and they haven't
done that before but I mean it's so
funny
it's a magnet yeah it was a different
type of group of people on there like it
was singers as dancers right some
rappers yeah like I liked um like they
like they had rare they had uh what's
the singer [__] names
Friday Friday's though I liked Friday on
there
um
uh what's going on there a little
brother she deserved to be on there glow
uh rifle man
I've seen people that's like more like
um EDM music that's what it's called
yeah
like EDM you feel me so I know like I
don't understand how big they are the
music is in their Lane you know no I'm
not saying I never I don't listen to
that music so I don't but we wouldn't
know but it looked like they do EDM you
get what I'm saying like Okay it looked
like they do EDM so what the [__] would
we know he said they look like
just like let's say this baby try and
stream more than everybody in Detroit
okay so you don't play him in the clubs
right you feel me no but he's one of our
top rappers right but you would never
hear baby child in the club but he got
some of the biggest songs it'd be like
somebody just going to the club and only
determining what's hot from from just
the one place no it's just no it's he's
from Detroit but like what his crowd is
it's a crowded [__] that's not
in the industry right right right he'll
make ghetto Rapture he don't make that
type of music
one of the best leaders first time I
played trying in the hood for for cousin
them on Van Dyke [__] same area y'all
was in [__] [__] like what the [__]
is this food what you got on the damn TV
and I'm like bro this [__] ass [__]
sweet I'm trying to hear y'all [__]
gonna get it